>> Bret: AT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
TOP DIPLOMAT SAID THE U.S. WILL
NOT BE AS SANCTIONS AGAINST
NORTH KOREA UNTIL
NORTH KOREA UNTIL IT GETS RID OF
ITS NUKES.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
WAS IN BEIJING TO DISCUSS THE
SUMMIT WITH CHINESE LEADERS.
>> SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO'S WEEKLONG ASIA TRIP
FOCUSED ON DISARMING THE NUCLEAR
ARSENAL CONCLUDES HERE WITH
COMMITMENT FROM CHINA TO
MAINTAIN PRESSURE ON
NORTH KOREA.
>> CHINA HAS REAFFIRMED ITS
COMMITMENT TO HONOR THE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL RESOLUTIONS.
THE SANCTIONS AND THE ECONOMIC
RELIEF THAT NORTH KOREA WILL
RECEIVE WILL ONLY HAPPEN AFTER
THE FULL DENUCLEARIZATION AND
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION OF
NORTH KOREA.
>> THE SECRETARY OF STATE ALSO
MET WITH FOREIGN MINISTER AND
OTHER OFFICIALS AT THE MINISTRY
OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
CHINA WANTS A REDUCED U.S.
MILITARY PRESENCE IN THE REGION,
AND APPROVES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DECISION TO
SUSPEND MILITARY ACTIONS WITH
SOUTH KOREA.
EARLIER TODAY, POMPEO WAS IN THE
CIVIL MEETING WITH MINISTERS
FROM SOUTH KOREA AND JAPAN.
HE DEFENDED THE DECISION, SAYING
IF NORTH KOREA FAILS TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH, THE
LESS WILL SIMPLY RESTORE THOSE
DRILLS.
POMPEO SAYS THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WILL ALSO INVOLVE AN INTENSE
ACCOUNTING OF THE SIZE AND SCOPE
OF KIM JONG UN'S NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
>> WE HAVE AN REASONABLE
UNDERSTANDING AND WE WILL WORK
WITH NORTH KOREANS TO COME TO
HAVE A FULLER UNDERSTANDING OF
THAT SO WE CAN BEGIN TO EXECUTE
TOGETHER THE COMMITMENTS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CHAIRMAN CAN
MAKE.
>> >> IN PYONGYANG, NORTH KOREAN
LEADERS ARE ALSO COMMEMORATING
CHAIRMAN KIM'S EXPERIENCE.
AND IN ONE SCENE, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SALUTING A GENERAL.
FROM NORTH KOREA.
>> THIS TRIP FOR
SECRETARY POMPEO ALSO FEATURED
PERSISTENT QUESTIONS AS TO WHAT
EXACTLY NORTH KOREA AGREED TO IN
SINGAPORE.
ONE JOURNALIST ASKED WHY
APPRAISING PHRASES WERE OMITTED
FROM THE FINAL DOCUMENT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN
SIGN.
POMPEO SAYS IT DID INCLUDE
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION WHICH
COVERS THOSE TERMS AND THAT THE